[Music]
all right man it's time I'm ready to
receive a little mysterio man we're
gonna watch the spider-man far from home
trailer it's yeah I haven't seen it I'm
seeing it fresh eyes right now as you
can see I of course I know Mysterio is a
villain we all know that I'm wearing my
proper shirt I'm in Mysterio fanboy mode
for those who see who this got my
Mysterio statue out master of mysticism
9 what up Jake Gyllenhaal I am a massive
Mysterio fan for those that don't follow
comics 20 years ago yeah in daredevil
the daredevil run that I did with Marvel
Knights with Joe Quesada Jimmy Tommy ah
T that is now celebrating his 20th
anniversary
Mysterio was the villain of my series
y'all might remember this if you were
reading comic books back in the day joke
aside a gorgeous cover Mysterio holding
thumbs up and there's daredevil trapped
inside of the fishbowl helmet so I'm
invested man I can't wait like [ __ ] him
when they said it's gonna be Mysterio I
was like what an age of wonder we live
in thank god I lived this long thank God
the hard to detect and didn't take me
because now we get to live in a world
where we see [ __ ] Mysterio on the big
screen this is [ __ ] up kids I know
you're probably used to this the younger
generation like of course we're getting
Mysterio we'll get everything we my
generation never expected to see this
[ __ ] you're lucky to see Mysterio in the
cartoons seem on the big screen played
by Jake Gyllenhaal of all people heavens
Brokeback Mountain Brokeback Mysterio
you know what I'm saying you saw the
movie this is gonna be fantastic man I
haven't seen this trail yet
watch it right now with you guys let's
spin her up I'm starting I skipped a
little head part where they show a
little quick flashes I'm starting on the
part says official trailer man so let's
let's do this let's [ __ ] dive in
goddamn it Mysterio here's my question
will we see Jake Gyllenhaal's face in
the trailer or are they just gonna go
fishbowl how they gonna accomplish this
will we even see Mysterio in the trailer
I don't know I'm assuming because he's
the bad guy and you know it's Jake
Gyllenhaal were they gonna hide them and
stuff so I'm hoping to god he's in there
I can't wait let's let us watch together
shall we
I'm getting ready to press play folks
and here we go Mysterio please action
thank you thank you leave me alone
happy and Aunt May it's fun I love
Favreau man and they old Favreau spine
of the monster man
[Music]
Holland good suit
I just Holland kids phenomenal sorry I'm
trying to watch
did you see the suitcase it was Uncle
Ben's suitcase the initials were Ben
Parker are you I'm doing pretty -
missing the ship now because I keep
trying it Mysterio so nice to finally
meet you
spider-man
it sure is [ __ ] before right
okay oh my God we're getting twice the
Nick area this year three times if he's
in Avengers
unique theory just hijacked their summer
vacation spidey goes European vacation
London Bridge is falling down gets
Parker job to do
are you going to step up right now we're
he's doing the blind squirrel thing
excellent out there all alone friends
are in trouble
what are you gonna do about it
the hydro man
ah you don't want any part of this
holy [ __ ] bubble and bubble [ __ ] ass
we have fishbowl helmet ladies gentlemen
who is that guy he's like Iron Man Thor
rolled into one
he's a Spider Man what do you say with
you and spider-man well he looks out for
the neighbor it has a dope suit and I
really respect him that's good
[ __ ] let's what has a lot to unpack
let's watch it again man
starting from the from the card oh [ __ ]
before we dive back in was that Hydra
man was that is Mysterio being presented
as good guy is he saying I'm a good guy
is he faking it I'm I'm in but holy [ __ ]
man they gave us Jake Gyllenhaal looks
like Brody from mall rats with the
facial hair and [ __ ] he looks good man
looks like he descended from Brokeback
Mountain was like you don't want any
part of this they showed him in the
fishbowl helmet ladies gentlemen [ __ ] I
know a lot of people are like mad at the
current state of the world and our
country [ __ ] but I'm sorry this just
makes up for it we [ __ ] at Mysterio in
a movie they keep giving me shiny
trinkets I won't pay attention to the
big picture so what I've been doing my
whole life let's dive back in shall we
[ __ ] man like ah what an age of wonder
we live in man never imagined you'd
[ __ ] see that [ __ ] in the big feet
it looks like that he's got the big
buttons big [ __ ] kick like doing this
[ __ ] right you kids don't remember
remember the first x-men movie or they
made jokes about not wearing their
costumes and [ __ ] they're like what
we're gonna do we're look I'll leotard
now their weirdness yet in the comics
[ __ ] it listen you don't hear for me
let's watch this again
Marissa Tomei Kadim II award Larisa to
me how adorable they got this little
relationship where she knows thank you
new dress I love Fabro man just happened
thank you good he's a great director and
he's really great I can watch him in
anyway
hey man it's the store owner that he's
saved in the last pose no date on that
pass no year you [ __ ] nuts
you're not gonna bring defend market
suits to the Ben Parker suitcase is
adorable so are these kids M&M dead
therefore I have value this is good man
pretty too I like her excusing that Hugh
Jackman
this guy - I love him he's funny as [ __ ]
so nice to finally meet you
spider-man thought ma'am but doing these
goddamn movies so right here put some
clothes on let's go for a ride is he
gonna be okay like that Nick Fury gonna
be in Avengers and swampers uli gonna be
in this and gonna be in Captain Marvel
all in the span of one year
fury just hijacked our summer vacation
[Music]
get gifts Parker job to do so are you
going to step up or not
goddammit that looks amazing keep
swinging Betty brands I like the black
out with the stubbed-out Dubai I like
the water man punches them and he goes
down that's awesome
Dennis that makes sense holy [ __ ] got
what have sex with them right now
yes who knew
I'm gonna cry it's so beautiful
he's got the [ __ ] glass helmet on who
knew that these movies needed Jake
Gyllenhaal so bad guy he's like Iron Man
and Thor rolled into one
he's no spider-man what is it with you
and spider-man what he looks out for the
neighbor it has a dope suit and I really
respect their sub dickwad [ __ ] these
kids are good man Tom Hollands is
[ __ ] genius there it is I'm happy
this puts a spring in my [ __ ] step
don't know about you guys but it could
all collapse today this this is a great
thing wow wow wow
I'm coming Arizona on Thursday if you
want to see me it's stand-up live with
Ralph's doing Hollywood babble-on then
I'm going to Saskatchewan for 3 shows
this week Ben Friday Saturday and Sunday
wondering one of which is in toontown
Saskatoon so come on out if you're in
those areas man tomorrow night deadly
class airs on Syfy we had a premiere
party last night where I got to is made
by the Russo brothers right they produce
it so I got to meet Anthony Russo and if
I could just blew him about these movies
I was like bro I've seen infinity war 53
times like and it just keeps getting
better I was just like Beetlejuice I
told them how important it is to me I
was like you're doing the Lord's work
man because like I shouldn't give a [ __ ]
about this I know how the sausage is
made man I work in the movie business
and yet these [ __ ] movies capture you
and but the show that did the classic
look they capture my imagination make me
feel young again
they make me forget that like I do this
for a living I'm obviously not that
nobody spider-man but like I'm in the
entertainment business too and I
completely [ __ ] forget and I just get
reduced to a total movie buff and fanboy
like I was when I was a kid I love that
feeling I love that somebody can make a
48 year-old man feel like he's 11
watching Raiders of the Lost Ark for the
first time so there it is man spider-man
far from home and was it coming July fit
I just have to stay alive until July 5th
that's it
hopefully by then they'll show me a few
more trailers and I'll stay alive for
them but Mysterio
you
you